put it this way I always do my best  songwriting here makes me feel less  lonely  you know sometimes I look around at all  of the people and  think  they might not know the woman at the  piano  could be a star one day I believe  are we supposed to be oh it's fine he'll  be back in five okay so you want to  start out with chord progressions so  let's see this  no I don't like that  it's okay let's work with that  [Music]  yeah okay  [Music]  it's all in my head it's all in my heart  the light always finds a way to shine  Through The Dark  it's way too late now for turning around  I'm right at the edge but I'm a figure  it out  one day they'll know my name  one day I'm gonna make it out this room  I don't have nothing to lose I'll be  patient cause I know it's on the way  they don't know my name  oh my God Heidi that was incredible